et
sur la tête de la première section de la
2e compagnie
situation familiale j'ai un enfant de 7
ans et mon épouse est avocat
[Musique]
un choix qu'il a faits ensemble et
j'assume les conséquences des questions
des soucis les angoisses ares je pense
que ça va très très bien se passer qui
saigne
on range part pour la passer c'est
on ne voulait pas passer
[Musique]
je redoute la robe pourpre et et alain
on vous demande pas d'avoir envie de
téléphoner pour ceux qui ont une femme
qui attend c'est un ordre
[Musique]
la plus connectée de tout quand même je
suis très amoureuse mais pour moi tu
sais pourquoi taire
c'est vrai que cette forme de vie
d'abord marié relationnel
c'est par qu'on se perde